hi there steve kaufman here
today i want to talk about motivation in
language learning you know i have bought
lots of books about
language instruction language
acquisition
i have them on my shelves i've read them
some have influenced me some of them i
find
totally contradicting my experience but
very little that i have found has been
written on the subject of
motivating people and yet i believe that
motivation is is the most important
factor in language learning so
i want to talk a bit today about
maybe i'll do a few videos on the
subject what motivates me from my
experience
and then i'd like to hear from you and
then i have some other ideas about how
in language instruction
we could do a better job of trying to
find those trigger points those
you know hooks
that are going to motivate people and
different people are motivated in
different ways i thought of this today
because
i was cleaning out
my garage we had we changed our
telephone system we got an old tv great
big heavy tv
uh we even changed our central vacuum
cleaner
um so i got to get rid of all the stuff
so i look up they recycle whatever
centers here and so i find out where i
go to take this stuff and i take it
there and there's some free recycling
run by the city and adjacent to it or
part of this complex
is this company that takes in all these
electrical or electronic goods
old high fives and everything else and
they whatever they're able to salvage
out of them they salvage it's a business
which is good
so and lo and behold everybody working
there is korean
so and the girl who who's there to
receive me and who i ask my questions uh
of
she's korean
so we start speaking in korean
and she was so happy and and really wow
and you speak so well of course which i
don't
and uh
so that motivated me and i said i'm
going to go back to korean i've got to
get further along in korean so there's
just a little spark like that
and prior to that
somebody uh i think on the youtube
channel had commented looking forward to
hearing you speak polish and i've been
letting the polish lag so that was a bit
of a
a bit of a motivator
but
in my own experience
you know those things aren't strong
enough they'll get me going for a while
but i have to have that good content i
should point out too that
last week
i traveled to the interior of bc and
in the summer if you have the
opportunity to travel by car in the
interior of bc it is spectacular so we
drove across the coast mountains
into kelowna this beautiful lake in the
okanagan which is a different
climate zone different
you know
type of
tree forest cover and stuff dryer
visited with a couple in their mid 80s
and we've known for a long time who
moved up there
and the fellow said he's 86 or 87 he's
still learning spanish
um
then we drove down through penticton
okanagan falls down to soyuz
and that country is so beautiful the
vineyards the fruit orchards
and we played golf and we visited some
vineyards where there's free wine
tasting we bought some wine delicious
wine there's a
small
winery called cassini
and we went there in there we sampled
different wines and we decided to buy
two cases of like six bottles each of
four different wines we just had some
this evening with dinner as syrah it was
phenomenal
and the owner showed up one day while we
were carting our two boxes away and he's
of italian origin but lived in romania
so i spoke of viewers of romanian
there's a motivation
but as i say that is less small
motivator it's not good enough i need
content of substance so you know i've
been reading this book di maki and soy
in spanish it's such a fascinating book
i just keep reading and i know that by
reading in spanish i am continuing to
improve my spanish it was only 10 years
ago that i that i read my first whole
book in spanish and i've never really
really been working that much at spanish
but
reading more books and i think plus
learning other languages my spanish has
improved i was able to read the book
almost like as if it were
english
so
the big issue remains content and i'm
still attracted to my russian and
ukrainian because i'm following the
events there so every day i listen to my
russian and ukrainian and i don't have
the time to go after my korean because
you can get stimulated that sort of
little spark of motivation
but then i need some interesting content
to keep me going so i'm going to stop it
here
but i want to talk next time
about
the how we can determine what motivates
people and how that could be introduced
into and teaching and if people have
ideas on that i would love to hear from
them so thank you for listening bye for
now